this former who's the ball star Alyssa
Milano is a huge football fan and that's
why she hit the Los Angeles Rams
training facility with easy on lines so
Keisha lacy you just reconnected with
your who's the boss castmates oh so fun
so fun we had the best time Tony came in
and he was like a tornado you know and
everyone was so excited to see him and
then he said just wait here one second I
gotta go get Lucy we were like Lucy who
is Lucy is it a new dog like what is
Lucia any proof he brought us this
little ukulele and he serenaded us for
like a good 15 minutes and it was so
sweet
we were there when they became one of
TV's favorite families and over 30 years
later this crew is still tight-knit I
mean we always email each other back and
forth and Tony's Grady he always asked
to see pictures of the kids the cast
reminisces about their days on the set
and Entertainment Weekly but now the mom
of two is gearing up for football season
what are your go-to gameday snacks I
live the Atkins lifestyle so I don't do
carbs or sugar anything like that okay
so what are some of your favorites to
eat to keep the calories from getting
too long okay so jerk chicken wings
cauliflower buffalo cauliflower is
delicious cheese everybody loves cheese
loved even though football is king and
Alyssa's house the sports loving family
isn't afraid to go to that my son is
actually he played Little League and my
husband's one of his coaches and I'm the
bench coach on the bench mom so what
does the bench mom do it's basically
like wrangling cats okay and I just need
a really long now that is real
well Allah has even turned her love of
sports into a side business she actually
has a line of fan gear for women called
Thai Chinese one of those jerseys